good morning everyone first and foremost
I want to say how proud I am of Mia and
Mia
so last night just freaking out a bit
she was like I do not know where I am so
we brought her in here she's kind of
pacing around and stuff because you got
to keep in mind she is a puppy and she
has never stayed outside of her house
so she's hearing all these noises you
know probably like the water and the
pipes people walking down the hallway
people driving and parking and all that
and um
the thing that we're worried about the
most is since we went on a big old hike
when we came to actually drank a big old
bucket of water
and we're like oh she's gonna pee and
poo I walked with her last night all up
and down
over here as you can see where all the
truck was parked I walk from that way
all the way down over there and then all
the way around to the back
and she does not want a pure poo she's
actually very particular where she wants
pure poo and I was like oh so we laid
out that towel over there in hopes that
if she needed to pee or poo
yeah that's she's cleaning herself yeah
well she's a multitasker look that's
disgusting well that's how they cleaned
themselves monkey
so yeah we're scheduling but she did it
that's what I'm so proud of you Mia and
this morning I walked her and then she
pooed so we're so happy that she got out
of her system
and um now I'm getting ready for
breakfast but I did go to the back of
this place in the morning and Mama
there's a little Lake back there we
gotta go take a look at it there's a
little gazebo and everything is CUNY and
monkey there's a giant horse and a cow
in the front
dang this steak looks really good
actually
I told them no hash browns and fruit but
right yeah that's cutie like so we're
down here getting breakfast at the diner
of the casino of the hotel exactly and
um it's the part right when you walk in
and the decor is so cool it's like
really really old school and out there
is a lake which we'll check out in a
little bit yeah
did you know I was reading about the
history of the name it's called Long
Street because it's based off of a
gunslinger I think his name is Jack
Longstreet
and he uh I was reading on on the menu
last night when I was ordering food and
he's apparently he's like the six foot
tall dude with piercing blue eyes and he
and yeah oh yeah and he never backs down
from a gun fight and everyone has ever
he's ever dropped has always been
defensive so he's not a bully
we got waffles we got oatmeal some
sourdough egg whites
this looks delicious
[Music]
oh yeah that makes it good
it actually smells good like they cooked
it on a grill like it smells Smoky which
is awesome just trimming the fat
look at that breakfast steak
Burger
[Music]
let's go mister
taika is so excited to see the animals
look how big this guy is you see him
there too I did not know there's a sheep
there oh
huh
[Music]
he's nice I thought he's nice
he's a nice guy
laughs
oh
look at his brother
oh yeah his brothers back there okay
after he said it a thousand times
just sitting
hello
it's huge
oh
right behind the casino in there's this
little Pond over here
and they even have their ducks and stuff
oh
God
oh yeah that is that is
so another thing that makes Long Street
and so convenient is they have their own
gas station
check it out so as I showed you guys
last night there's nothing miles on that
end and Death Valley is that way
Death Valley National Park so it's
really convenient that it's a One-Stop
shop you come here you can stay here
overnight or a couple days there's a
little supermarket in there and I'm
pumping gas now
it's always good to top it off whenever
you can when you're traveling
it's just never know what happened like
blow a tire
um you can get lost and now you have to
reroute everything
so we were driving on our way to go to
the Death Valley Visitor Center to grab
some stickers to put on our cooler
because you guys know that's what we're
trying to do and as soon as we drove
through here and we saw these crazy like
yellow looking rock formations we had to
pull over because we could just imagine
like in between those two it's probably
like completely like yellow or cream
looking so this was insane
all right you know what's crazy we
thought this is Rock it's actually just
yeah we thought it was Stone but it's
just sand look like the whole thing just
comes off look
whoa look how strong I am I broke stone
okay go
that's crazy
this whole thing is just sand like what
that's insane
all right I just climbed up of course
this monkey has to follow me look at
this cool View
and rocketing everywhere
and trucks all there over there
dude this place looks like we're on
another planet you could totally shoot
space stuff here and me is that whoa she
got crazy hops she's having a blast
go protect like uh
this place is nuts look at that
[Music]
look at me a go look at me a girl
good job miak all the up to taika
Mia come down
I love seeing her come down when she
Sprints down
and then she lets the like this oh cool
come here Mia Mia come down come here
come here good girl
there she goes there she goes look
There She Goes so badass
right there
the crevice there you go there you go
come here good girl good girl
man
wow
[Music]
so I think taika is trying to go to the
top
which means we gotta follow the boss
so we're going up two now but it's cool
because as we're coming up look at this
View
okay we're pretty close to the top
but the floor is really soft so we're
scared it's going to cause a sand
Avalanche because you can see Azure walk
like it crumbles so we're not gonna go
to the top but this view
is crazy
look at the way this looks all these
wrinkles looks like brain wrinkles
that's crazy this guy's turning into a
straight dirt bag
oh
my God
it doesn't stop it doesn't stop at all
there's like rattlesnakes in there
yup be careful
so now we're at the Furnace Creek
Visitor Center
which is like right smack in the middle
of uh Death Valley National Park and our
goal is hopefully we get to find a
sticker here to put a new sticker on our
cooler you know what to look for right
mister
you know what to look for right
yep
come here I'm gonna show you something
monkey look
so this is where we are right here this
blue
this is Death Valley we're gonna be
driving all the way up all the way up to
here Mammoth Lake
so you're driving all the way up
California
[Music]
pretty cool huh
we started where we started Las Vegas
hey monkey we start over here
they started Las Vegas and then we're
driving and we went all the way
to here where the blue is and then we're
going all the way up to Mammoth Lakes
and then to Lake Tahoe and it's
Grandma's house oh my God
hit the jackpot which one's cool oh a
ram look that one's RAM and as a rainbow
yeah
you can get it yeah you can keep that
for yourself but we can't we don't know
where that is
what does it say it says dvnp
what is this for yeah
let's go look at the map sure
because now we're putting on sticker
number two
I think you need help
you what do you want me point where you
want to put it first like a wipe it
clean right here or right here right
here where where right there that's a
good spot I like it okay
moment
you have to paint it okay you have to
clean it
oh God that's the worst why don't they
do it where it like splits in the back I
know right
ah there you go okay hold on hold up
I'll help you
okay you hold this one I'll hold this
side ready
put where you want to put it right here
there you go I snuck in place
good job mister
grab so much before we head to mad
that's gonna be
gonna be an instrument
that Valley is called the Inn I actually
wanted to come here because from the
pictures it looks insane like a lace in
the middle of the dancer like there's so
many
teams and the thing is
plus that covers like the whole trip
because our alternative yesterday that
you guys just saw that was only like 100
bucks
per night
I feel like no way Jose
so it's still cool
we're still packing this I could check
it out
because they get restaurant what whoa
the tunnel for the elevators like this
whoa that's so cool
I've ever seen
[Applause]
how cool is this
[Music]
cool huh
the corn here is freaking cool it's like
really old school like uh like but like
High
Society is the word I guess
everything got like this gold trim
pictures of Death Valley got this
boardroom with some old-school furniture
through here
the only thing is we didn't make
reservations so who knows what's gonna
happen but it feels pretty cool so far
it's good too
oh cool
looks like it's quite empty so it should
be good
see look at that see that's like a
full-on resort resort where it's like
green and it has grass and like palm
trees everywhere in the middle
of the desert
unfortunately
there's a private event going on
so they said we cannot die in here I
believe the next restaurant honestly is
like
a few hours away so the cool thing is we
do have our cooler that's packed with
food
so we we could eat that and the plan B
would be we're just gonna get on the
road now to head towards Mammoth because
it is going to be a good four and a half
hour drive I know this guy's sleepy he
has like droopy eyes so wow dude I saw
your eyes going like this like this
you were going like that
yeah where are you going like this look
are you sure baby
those eyes are look
all right like I said Plan B because the
restaurant is shut down good thing we
had all the backup food because there's
going to be zero restaurants for a good
four hours so my Bear's making some
Hawaiian bread sandwiches which is
delicious this guy's smiling all big
over here can I help her go ahead oh do
you hear how windy it is outside yeah
can I help her yeah go ahead she might
blow away you gotta go you gotta go out
that door though without dropping any of
that stuff because you can't climb over
it's all chips you're gonna Crush
everything no way Jose
okay
don't kick anything there you go
I'm gonna help you okay help Mama
oh no I don't need your help okay Mama
doesn't need your help thank you let's
go back let's go back this way because
anything will knock my whole setup okay
yeah it's very fragile
huh Can I please help you no you can't I
need to open this stuff well you feel
that the whole truck is shaking that is
crazy
whoa that is insane
all right
sandwich number one going down the hatch
it looks really good Mama
I'm waiting for Mama and the son
to eat some of the yummy food
before I eat one of my disgusting uh
that's not disgusting but it's just more
health conscious
nothing goes wrong with that I got your
water
can I switch with you now so I can make
my food
so not the best meal but I'll get the
job done got some ground beef that I
made got a good eight ounces put some
mustard got some fat free ranch
gonna
we don't have any utensils I'm gonna
just Stir It Up with this knife that I
just cleaned and I just eat with this
knife right here
and uh
call it a meal but that'll be enough to
hold me over and we can eat something
delicious once we get to Mammoth
Mammoth Lakes
see look
back
not bad at all
you got boogies coming out your nose
dude
not gonna lie
it's actually pretty good
this like mustard and French and ground
beef
oh no I'm not lying it's uh it's
actually pretty moist wished it was warm
but
if you ever had any camping food
or cold MREs
is literally what it tastes like
so MRIs for sure way better when you can
heat it up
but most of the time you don't have that
luxury
so
same thing where it's not bad at all
could be way worse
and I I Could Have Cheated at the
restaurant got like a whole big ass
basket of french fries because I just
said effort or something but
stuck to the diet pretty good
and I know that's gonna situate me
because look how good eight ounces of
ground beef right here
all right
sleep station is ready
recipe I like get the what is like the
brush that takes the hair off yeah
in a vacuum
right here
watch your little pawpaws
there we go
close this
lock it
if you guys like this system this is
called the Diamondback super sick I love
this thing supports 500 pounds on top so
it's technically a flatbed
a lot of people see this and they go
the truck no that's not how it works
it's technically a flat bit now which is
a true truck this is locked ready to go
time to get
the show on the road one thing that's
pretty crazy it's sometimes really hard
to get reception
so I couldn't map it I did look on my
phone
and I took the I took a couple of
screenshots
as I left on the on the map of my phone
for some reason I could not
I could map I mean I can't map but I can
take screenshots so I know what to take
like the the 190 the 395.
so I have to put it together in my brain
but also when I was upstairs at the
resort
um trying to get some food I found a
little business center so I was able to
print out old school Google Maps
remember MapQuest guys
but yeah I'll be following this and
we'll be going from here
all the way up to Mammoth Lakes
one of my favorite things about road
trips is also passing through little
towns on the way to the main destination
I don't know how many of these little
towns we've passed already but every
time we go through they're so CUNY look
at this okay it's so blown out
yeah but it looks I know what what do
you mean
no but it looks like everything is like
a mom and pop shop and it's like from a
long time ago like that that boot shop
is from
1922. it's so cool yeah I love seeing
little shops like this this looks like
Whittier Boulevard but just the White
Version okay dude it does but it also
looks well kept like I said the White
Version dude we also sell boots
look how crazy this is we were just in a
Barren desert in Death Valley and look
at how much everything has changed this
is literally just a white we are in
Winter Wonderland complete 180 from
wearing t-shirts to now bundle that this
is crazy
foreign
nuts
you're sinking into the snow
all right so this is crazy
where it's so white you can't tell where
the snow starts and where the sky starts
or it ends look
[Music]
crazy
dude look at this wall all right so this
is a real snow town this guy gotta plow
the streets just so people can drive I
know their business is straight up
covered
people gotta pump gas that is crazy how
are they even gonna get in there well
they cut like a big Cole hon of course
well you're on the other lane get over
oh God oh yeah look at the Shell you
gotta go in there oh my goodness
dude I'm so glad we brought this truck
we're about to bring our SUV we have
soup we have super four-wheel drive and
we got Big old tires so thank goodness
hey if that Subaru could do it well he
probably has chains on we have to get
chains for your car he doesn't have
chains on them sure
yes oh that's true you do
you just gotta one up me all the time
go
is it soft yep
very soft
whoa let me see
bro that's oh that is so cool
um don't stand hey come here don't stand
underneath them because they could break
and then it'll land right on top of you
but look at the gondolas dude
oh cool
I see Mammoth on him
they'll be all wet dude
this is so nuts how much snow there is
just got to the hotel and unloaded the
family so this is the lesson which is a
very big hotel and even this is
completely covered in snow one thing
that I did not know about Mammoth that
I'm a huge fan of now is that it's built
into the resort
so all of these hotels are built into
the resort like if you go to Big Bear
all the hotels are at the bottom of the
mountain right and then you still got a
drive to get to where you snowboard
this place is such snowboard Central
that although hotels are built into the
mountain so you can have constant
Gondola rides like everyone was just
walking straight out of the hotel with
the snowboard they don't even have to
get in the car they just walk down there
get into the gondola station and they're
just riding all the way up
that is so freaking cool
this is so much more convenient than Big
Bear because the Big Bear
you still gotta get out of your cabin
get out of your hotel load your truck
and all that like
all of I have never thought that's a
genius thing to build into the mountain
resort that is freaking sick well
anyways um now I gotta park the car I'm
still in awe that this is what happened
but my truck looks so dope in the snow
oh man
it's a family church I didn't bring a
snowboard or anything but it's still
freaking rad like look at this literally
everything is buried this is the
entrance had they not carved that out
that would have just been like eight
feet of snow blocking the entrance
and you can tell they haven't moved
these cars in a while because those guys
are just straight up covered in snow
this is crazy the centerpiece covered in
snow
look how thick the snow is on that roof
oh my God
okay you can tell this hotel
is nice nice
look at that
dude this is the ultimate
snowboard Heaven imagine you just come
out here
with their snowboard and he hit the
slopes and you get to come back and
sleep in luxury because sometimes you
rent those cabins and those cabins will
have like a shared wall with the next
cabin and you got a bunch of Rowdy like
Frat Boys or something making all kinds
of noise next door you don't really
sleep or you're with their family and
then you hear a bunch of like young
people just and you know
this is like
straight up like Vegas hotel in the
middle of the mountains this is bugging
rad
okay where are we at I'm excited
aha
let's see what they're up to
it's so cool in here is it whoa is this
high ceiling Hotel yeah holy is that a
stove yeah oh my God the hot tub and a
Jacuzzi look at how cool it sticks
straight up we're living here I know oh
this is just this is for like you're
smoking like a mud room oh my there's a
fireplace in here too yeah oh no okay
whoa there's a fireplace yeah this
is incredible
I don't even know but this room
yeah I think everyone look how freaking
he was distinguished gentlemen
this room is insane
what
this is a baller ass hotel room look at
the view
there's like a restaurant downstairs but
it's not probably not like a freeway gym
right I don't know yeah in the morning I
still gotta go train train but look at
this view Jesus
I feel like we're in Switzerland
holy moly oh look at that ice
look at that ice
look at this big icicle look
you see that big ice out the window
okay
so I thought this hotel was Next Level
already but look at this there's a dish
straight up knife set and a dishwasher
oh my what hotel comes with the knife
set
you could be making steaks up in here
what the
this hotel is legit what do you got we
gotta come back here again we got
we got to come back here babe this is
sick yeah
yeah there's on the hotel we like yeah
we gotta we gotta come back here and
stay for like a week
we have our own
short our own electrical
turn it off
yeah bus fuse
look at this
wow oh rain shower wow so they do have a
swimming pool and a Jacuzzi you want to
go or no yeah it's on the second floor
do you want to go you wanna just chill a
little bit
um doesn't matter okay we can do
whatever that's what the king wants
the king he's a leader yeah he's the
leader of the trip let me just hook her
up with water okay
sit
good girl no come on whoa oh she loves
it it's cutie she's the best so we're
just out walking her I forgot to put in
the room the dog into the restaurant
make sure she pees her boos but this
snow is
So Soft oh my God
okay monkey do say he saw the biggest
icico he's ever seen where is it what
dude that thing is gnarly
that for sure is the biggest one I've
ever seen how's it connected
straw yeah
it's gonna fall all the way down to
there to the ground yep yep and that's
the pool right there that we're gonna go
check out whoa that's a big hot tub
yeah and look at all those icicles
right there
[Music]
over there
oh you don't have to get everything no
of course not Oh I thought you gave it
to him
okay baby
let's go
[Music]
oh there's a gym here
everybody's working hard
oh this is nice this is so nice
can you imagine in the summer time where
you're like you're next to all these
trees and stuff the water's warm
let's see let's feel it we'll come back
in a little bit
oh yeah that's nice
can you put my foot in there no why
would you want to get wet it's gonna be
so cold how's that one
yeah like warm warm or a little bit warm
this is a nice pool
let's see
oh that is comfortable I mean compared
to outside compared to outside is really
warm so that's a hot tub is that a hot
tub or is that more like a kid's pool
what is that
[Music]
that's beautiful
the menu is pretty legit
yeah what was it what kind of stuff do
they have chicken noodle soup for one
usually kid menus they have like chicken
tenders and pizza and quesadilla yeah
yeah like it's garbage yeah chicken
noodle soup for sick kid doesn't even
have like a fruit smoothie what okay
look at this Japanese winter Curry isn't
that crazy and then double pork chops so
every place you should have a steak but
even like a pan roasted salmon with
butternut squash puree that is freaking
legit my eye caught the black bottom
peanut butter pie
oh and when you can get oysters you know
that I'm messing around
all right so Mama ordered some
appetizers I'm just getting Fancy with
the Shiseido this is massive though
smoothie it's a kid smoothie and I was
like can I get lunch is it good it's
really good she says do you like it is
like a smoothie
yeah
it's pretty good
what does it taste like a baby it has a
very mammoth
[Music]
oh my God
those french fries like bomb can we get
can we get a napkin
oh no we were doing so good it's okay
be careful don't move this okay you
spilled it mister you bumped it
what do you need
got a big old 16 ounce Ribeye want some
they look like they cooked it good too
yeah they did oh they did yes they did I
do but you eat it first you eat it first
you could try some
yeah
french fries look good too all right
look at the young man
how does it feel is it nice and warm
yeah it's called Uh oh my God it's so
cold out here
oh my goodness well she wants to get him
on her own
you need me
is you gonna get in she's licking it
don't lick it it's nasty chlorine water
oh my God all right time for me to get
into because it's freaking freezing
outside in the middle of a snowstorm
that is free to see
everything
oh my God
wrapping down the night
mama's taking a shower
we got Mia all dried up her fur looking
extra fluffy
give her a little plastic cup as a toy
so she's not bored or she ripped it all
up of course
we got this little hairless monkey ready
for bed that's his little sleep setup
so we'll see you guys for more
Adventures tomorrow good night
[Music]
that's cool